der schnelle imbiss für zwischendurch
mit zwiebeln geschnitten oder in einem
stück die currywurst es gibt sie mit
pommes oder mit einem brötchen kudamm
195 in berlin charlottenburg
diese bereifung die schnell schneiden
und bankette oder eine scharfe spezial
dose darüber geben
quot gefragten ständig gedreht täglich
frische fed muss sein wo die wurst drin
gebraten wird bastian fed wieder ein
geheimnis jeder macht es anders wir
haben unsere
an die 500 imbissbuden gibt es in berlin
rund 600.000 currywürste im jahr gehen
allein an zinsen stand im stadtteil
kreuzberg über die theke die currywurst
besteht hier aus schweinefleisch bip mit
dem rund eine berliner variante ohne
darm
bei den schlitz gerne berlin immer was
los ob nur die handwerker sind die tour
ist am wochenende meine kollegen bisdorf
innerhalb wechsel weg verkaufen weil die
leute kommen die leute noch in den warum
hat die überraschende 3 hat wir haben
hunger
das fand ich diese billige effekte sind
die berlinerin herta heuwer gilt als
erfinderin der currywurst
wie will als erste mit ketchup
currypulver und mutter rose
experimentiert haben ihre soße ließ sie
1959 patentieren darf dokumentiert das
deutsche currywurst museum in berlin
dezember 19 49 verschiedene zu fassen
zusammen und kreierte die currywurst und
ihren verkaufsstand auch die erste
currywurst raterei der welt und so wird
ihr die erfindung geschichte eigentlich
hier in berlin auch zugesagt aber auch
das ruhrgebiet und hamburg beanspruchen
die currywurst erfunden zu haben
die zubereitung variiert regional so
wurde der hamburger edel imbiss curry
queen schon mehrfach in gießen über mio
hochwertiges fleisch vom befüllen oder
auch google rim wird ihr pferd artikeln
die beiden haben grüner salat oder
aufgemachter referat den curry gewürzen
können sich die kunden
[Musik]
wir haben sieben verschiedene klagen von
ganz mild bis extrem scharf aber uns
gibt natürlich viel mehr um die aromen
weniger unschärfen gerade gibt eines mit
vier bis plus für mittleres dann
wirklich wieder haben wirklich ganz
tolles essen kinder auch gerne aber das
dorfbild und schüler auf die da gibt's
eine spannendere es gibt 1 mit
zitronengras geflügel klassisches
verlaufen war
im berliner stadtteil prenzlauer berg
ist man mehr gewinnerin knopp ihr
fragiles imbiss begann schon 1960 im
damaligen ostberlin das geschäft mit der
karwoche den fleisch hatten vom cappella
probierten wir auch prominent diesen us
dollar keine tomaten karotten tomaten
partner zugeteilt bekommen
hamburg von britta schätzel stück auf
und dann haben wir so lange probiert bei
diesen geschmack äußerten feinripp das
sollte filmten gut ankommt
[Musik]
das super job und ich finde das auch
wichtig also gerade bei einer currywurst
schmeckt gut
in berlin hamburg oder in moorrege der
currywurst fehlt in deutschland für den
kulinarischen und klappen kann
[Musik]
euro